please welcome father John misty
[Applause]
[Music]
hi welcome welcome to Scandinavia it's
Norwegian it's fine
no hate after the dough came out I've
been watching backstage got picked it up
[Laughter]
tell me how do you do how would how do
you deal with fame do you see it as
curse or a blessing well you have to
bear in mind that the level of fame that
I have you could drown in the sink with
little to no effort oh wow I would say
that yeah in in that when it comes to
fame the thing that people love about
you
in all likelihood doesn't actually exist
and I think it's kind of a realization
that people deal with in different ways
if someone is self-aware enough to
realize that and they're also prone to
depression or they're sensitive it can
be a deadly realization I don't have to
worry about any of this because I'm not
self-aware at all do you not know no I'm
fully believed that I deserve every I'm
also incredibly happy that's actually a
characteristic of wealthy people in
America they're they believe that their
wealth is proportionate exactly to how
hard they work and how smart they are so
they deserve every delusional yeah you
did you grow up with pop music or it was
that something that came late in life I
mean from a very Christian family and I
grew up well I grew up with a lot of
Christian pop music that's the one
helping not to be Christian yeah I mean
it was yeah so it wouldn't be like
Michael Jackson or that that kind of
just ordinary pizza I mean it sounded a
lot I mean there's this music that
sounded a lot like Michael Jackson but
it was about you know the end of the
world
and
hopefully not going to hell oh really
uplifting themes I mean that maybe we're
I mean if I mean 9 out of every 10 if my
songs are about the end of the world so
this is a radio main top I think I'm
starting I think we're starting to put
together why I'm not so popular I know
that while rehearsing you you you asked
our like manager named okay if he could
give the stage sort of an LSD feel I did
not say that so you get your mother to
mother should to say that or someone
said it my manager may have may have
said that oh you are no longer my
manager I said a cocaine feel
[Applause]
hope you enjoyed the clip for more
interesting conversations please hit
subscribe